[Music]
okay what's up everyone this is zacky
from geek culture and today we have the
zoids wild series toys for you uh this
is spoilage in 2018. and what we're
going to do today is we're going to
focus on the zw12 death racks it's going
to be a big build
if you've seen our simple build for this
wild lager special edition
yeah this is gonna be a series on a few
of these we're gonna cover the
graciosaurus the stegosaurus and a few
more of the zodiac's world series boys
this is my first time doing this
building zoids or actually any other
kind of toys i haven't now i've not
built or played with gundams or macros
or things like that so i'm pretty
excited to see how long it's gonna take
let's get the show on road and start
building
[Music]
you
uh
[Music]
so
give it a run and see what everything is
working probably
that's pretty cool
okay
all right so i'm guessing something
comes out like that so
cool
cool beans okay
so let's go and get started with the red
armor blipping
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so here we have it the
zoid wild death threats it was a fun bit
i must say it wasn't too hard if you
follow the instructions you wouldn't
have a hard time even though it's in a
different language in japanese and it's
pretty straightforward yeah no problems
with that frustration wise i guess it
takes a little bit of patience you know
it's a very plug-and-play thing so you
can expect uh with a bit of rough
handling or things to
for things to come out
yeah so you know if you want to take
time out to
you know build something of your own and
you know it's not only just the
experience of building but
also to see your kids come to life so
why don't we just take a test
[Music]
right so these are the functions i'm not
sure they can see it but
let me try and turn this around you can
see that the
small thingy comes out
there we go
[Music]
it's lighting up
it's charging
you know we had something
all right hope that you guys like this
video uh please comment share and don't
forget to like if you have any of this
zoids or if you want to see any more
videos on uh toy builds let us know in
the comments below i'll be happy to sort
that out for you guys so until next time
this is zeki and hope to see you soon
here on heat culture